on this very stormy day in parts of the
mid-atlantic states and the southeast we
turn to the military's Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency which back in
1958 helped put the first weather
satellite into space this year DARPA
celebrates 60 years of stunning
inventions that have kept the United
States on the cutting edge of technology
kylie atwood spoke with some of their
scientists and read i've immediately
been alerted there's a threat over there
this is a Ghostbusters rig on a
real-life mission if that was a
55-gallon drum full of ammonium nitrate
that would be a very big blast today
American soldiers must be inches away to
identify a chemical warfare agent or a
homemade bomb but by next year they'll
be able to do that from as far as 100
feet away any chemical that's a threat
to a soldier we try to detect the first
Edie daughter ease quest is backed by
the Pentagon's Defense Advanced Research
Projects Agency also known as DARPA the
biggest threat right now is probably
homemade explosives if you think of
fertilizer and that's what they're using
today in Afghanistan to try and blow up
our soldiers with the help of DARPA the
goal is to shrink this 30 pound backpack
into a handheld device DARPA is really
an engine with inside the Defense
Department challenging our military
services to think differently
Steven Walker's DARPA director it's
important for DARPA to understand the
technology to then be able to explain it
to our war fighters and our policymakers
and not be surprised by its use or
misused by your adversary DARPA helped
create the internet unmanned aerial
drones prosthetic limbs and Siri it was
created in 1958 in response to the earth
shattering launch of Sputnik by the
Soviet Union America was surprised when
the Russians launched Sputnik do you
think we'll ever see something like that
happen again where the u.s. is caught
off guard it's hard to predict the
future but DARPA program managers come
to work every day with their hair on
fire to prevent technological surprise
so
and really the way we found to do that
best over the years is to create it by a
team of mad scientists like and Fisher
we're driven by crazy that's for sure
how can you be just a step back from
crazy so that we can kind of take a risk
and then see what we can do in terms of
making that risk realizable and I think
about this as my way for service to
national security DARPA is also working
on how to shrink mini robots like these
into a size smaller than a human
fingertip hoping they could save lives
during recovery efforts detecting signs
of life underneath the rubble of
collapsed buildings
first they have to prove their strength
we'd like to have them compete in a rock
pile and competition Oh biathlon
competition where we will have them
traverse a course and these drones are
being developed to navigate on their own
the line here shows the drones brain
mapping a course by avoiding obstacles
instructing the robot to go up find a
second-story window go through the
second-story window explore the entire
second floor find a staircase descend
the staircase and go out through the
front door all on its own this is pretty
sneaky
we prefer to think of it as intelligent
drone engineers say their main
competition comes from China they're
challenging us in different domains
where we used to have a significant lead
and it's more of a competition now and
what do you say to those who believe
that the US has already fallen behind in
the technology realm I'm not as negative
I think I think we still got a lot to
offer are they wrong I would say they
don't know everything that's going on
we're being challenged no question in
certain areas but I see what we're doing
at DARPA in all areas and I'm pretty
hopeful that we're gonna continue to win
the tech races of this 21st century
kylie atwood CBS news Oxon Hill Maryland
thank you I like a group of scientists
that go to work with their hair on fire
I love that there are very smart people
like that working on thinking about all
these problems